depuis 15 ans a notamment salué doit
s'écraser dans la région parisienne a
pas vraiment de familles y vivent à
l'émission déplorable l'hôtel toujours
hanté son côté rue un immeuble presque
banal mais côté cour le bâtiment livre
c'est shipwreck annuler fissuré qui
laisse couler l'eau des toilettes à
l'intérieur les conditions de sécurité
plus que douteuses dans cet hôtel de 22
chambres de 10 mètres carrés où
s'entassent quarante et une personnes
dont 13 enfants en bas âge une gestion
ou le profil règne en maître sur
plusieurs essais vous unir aucun et
chambre nouveau tunnel de le court a
deux jours pour payer le loyer est ce
qu'on vient vous fait payer par mois il
prend n'y pas d'eau courante
tous dans les toilettes communes par
étage raconte salubrité la mairie la
préfecture la das ont tenté d'intervenir
sans succès aujourd'hui le maire actuel
ne comprend pas lui non plus
probablement le fait
c'est pas facile d'enlever le maire et
le préfet en premier de reloger les
familles avec des enfants avant le 1er
mai à cette date
l'hôtel sera permis